I think the basic things I mean it's
like it's like kind of trying to sort of
D glamorize the idea of writer than the
writer from a lot of them because I
think you know that I think that there
is this kind of your hemingway-esque
in the borough's asking sort of myth
about the right or as this kind of
outlaw can hard-drinking can dole or
figure and you know I think that you
know it's a quite a glamorous kinda myth
but basically it's a boring job is about
hard workers it but certain in front of
a computer until your eyes are ready to
follow your head you know it's just it's
just kind of boring and lonely kind of
graft and toil you know and unless you
really enjoy you actually really vibe on
doing that kind of thing it's maybe
something that you you it's not for you
you know so I think that trying to
encourage people but you know but it's
the basic thing about writing being
rewrite and you know it's like you know
you just keep on and keep chipping away
and also it was done and not really and
not really being swayed by the idea of
superficialities the idea that you can
write a best-seller or that's kind of
nonsense oh well the idea that you came
to from the deserts and trends and
glamour and in the writers life and all
you know but there isn't really I mean
you kind of from the the sort of
interesting thing about being successful
is that you do get to travel and go all
these literary festivals and sort of
hang out with different people and stuff
like that but it's just such a small
part of the the biggest part of it it's
just kind of the sheer solid carry the
mind-numbing draft